me
[音楽]
皆さん
ここにある水
ある重さを例えているんですけれども何かわかりますか
ちょっと難しいですよね
私くらいの背格好の方の怪獣の4分の1の重さの水です
2 l のペットボトルなので男性の方だったら
あと3本くらい追加する感じになりますかね
どうですか皆さん
ご自身の体重の4分の1の重さ
イメージできましたか
では想像してみてください
その体重の4分の1の重さの重りを背負って
1 l の水等を首から提げて
3 chip 歩かないとあなたの職場に
学校につきません
ひとによっては40分の人もいます
50分の人もいるかもしれません
ついてからそのヒロ日課が始まります
そのような日常が
ずっと続くと言われたら
そのまま受け入れることが出来る人は
いるでしょうか
まあ言われたら仕方がないぜいぜいできるよという方
よろしければ挙手していただけますか
アジェンぜひ全然ないんですね
まあ本当に皆さん
何か変えなくてはいけない何か変えてほしいと思う方が動き出す方がほとんどではない
かと思います
現在小学1年生の平均体重が20キロ程度であることに対して
毎日学校へ持って行く荷物の総量が
5キロを超えることは稀ではありません
総体重の4分の1の重さです
このように1年生の荷物量の平均が6キロを超えるというデータもあります
5キロ6キロの荷物大人でもやですよねー
でもこの荷物は学年は上がるごとに増え
高学年になると10キロを超える荷物を持っている子もいるんです
ここにある水全部を背負っている子もいるはずです
ゆとり教育が終わり教科書のページ数が例年増加しています
小学生のお子さんが6年間で習う教科書の総ページ数は平成17年度から比べるとなん
と7割も増えているんです
しかもサイズが大きくなり髪がよくなり
とにかく重くなっています
なぜ私がこのようなことをお話しするのかというと
私の娘が小学校に入学して3日れ
ランとそれをせおと肩が痛いというはじめ
その後も
荷物が重い入りきらない使いにくいと
不満が続いたんです
改めて見てみると子どもが毎日使うものとしてはおかしいんじゃないかと思う所が
たくさんあることに気がつきました
もちろん一般的な
高価な
とても良いランドセルです
ランドセルは子どもが毎日使うもの
つまり=日用品のはずですよね
皆さんはご自身の鞄を選ぶときにどの会で選びますか
お出かけ用にちょっといいブランドバッグ
仕事用に書類がたくさん生えるバック
旅行用にとにかく軽いバック
毎日使うものだったらさらに昨日も気になるはずです
飲み物はすぐに出した絵からペットボトルが入れれるようなポケットが外側に付いて
いると便利だなーとか
鍵とか財布はすぐ出せるうちにポケットが欲しいなとか
リュックだったら背中が暑いだろうからメッシュになっているといいなと
肩ベルトを固定するバックルが付いてると楽だよなとか
お子さんが使うランドセルはどうでしょう
まず毎日使う日用品のはずですよね
たくさんある気もします
皆さんランドセルはどのように選んでいるんでしょうか
みんなが使っているから
まず大前提に彼はや合皮のランドセル
こう答える方がほとんどです
私もそう
当たり前に思って選びました
価格は平均で5万円を超え
10万円以上するランドセルも珍しくありません
でも価格も問題にならないんです
なぜ
でもバーンみんなが使っているからこのランドセル
子どもたちがこんなに辛くて過酷な毎日を過ごす理由がそれだけなのは
何かおかしいのではないかと感じました
いつからか
初節句にお雛様を送るように留学祝いにランドセルを贈る文化が定着しています
お祝い品ですからより上質な良いものを贈りたいと
贈る側の祖父母の方やご両親は思うでしょう
年々減少する新入学生の心を見た目でつかむために
華やかで煌びやかな装飾が好きカラーバリエーションも豊富に揃っています
でも現在一般的なランドセルの外側にポケットなんてありません
硬い皮の肩ベルトで重い荷物はさらに肩に食い込みます
6年間で30センチ以上身長が伸びるお子さんもいる中1年生の入学前に購入した
画一的なランドセルサイズのランドセルを6年間使用し続けます
体に合わせて選ぶなんてこともありません
ご自身で毎日使うものにそんなカバンを選びますか
何より
重さがランドセルだけで1100から1600g
1.6キロもあるんです
人は体重の15%以上の荷物を持つと体幹に影響があると言われています
重い荷物は成長期のお子さんの骨や信長への悪影響も心配されています
実際肩こりや腰痛背骨の歪みなどの深刻な症状を訴えるお子さんも非常に増えています
ランドセルが重いなら送り迎えしてあげればいいよ
という方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
教科書なんて学校において来ちゃえばいいという方もいらっしゃると思います
でも
送り迎えなんてみんなができるわけじゃないですし
そういう問題じゃないんです
学校2教科書を置いてくる置き勉も推奨はされましたが実際は学校ごとの決まりが
厳しく大きく進んでいる学校はほとんどありません
調べてみると
文部科学省や各自治体の教育委員会で通学か倍の決まりがあるところはほとんどない
ことが分かりました
実際このようなナイロン製のリュックのようなランドセルを使っている自治体が全国に
はいくつかあることも分かりました
でも周りの地域にすら波及していないです
理由は
ランドセルからはかなり遠いデザインと使いやすさにあるのではと感じました
ならば
自分たちで本当に使いやすくて
子供に安心して使わせることができるそんなランドセルを作ってみようと思いました
軽量で大容量で
高性能リュックのように使いやすい
ナイロン製のランドセルです
重さは770g です
だった500g くらいの違いだったら大したことないと思うでしょうか
体重が20キロのお子さんにとっての500グラフは体重が40キロだったら1 k
体重が60キロだったら1.5キロの重さに相当します
これが鞄の重さにプラスされるです
こう見ると結構大きいですよね
他にも水筒を入れるポケットや小物を入れるポケットを外側につけたり
柔らかいか食べるとか体にフィットして
いた日もなく
大容量で手荷物もほとんどなくなります
このランドセルを買ってくれたら安心ですよ
とお話をしに来たわけではないんです
実際販売はスタートしましたが苦戦しています
お話をすると
子どもたちに本当にいいのはこういうランドセルだろうねと言ってくださる方が
ほとんどです
なのに選んでもらえない理由
それは
皆と同じじゃないからです
親御さんは言うんです
みんなと違うランドセルを使っていたらいじめられるかもしれないよ
それを聞いたお子さんは
これを使ったらいじめられるんじゃ困るなぁん
それに
みんなと違うものを使っている子がいたらいじめてもいいのかな
そう思わないよ子さんは言うでしょうか
ウェアーとせるを作る過程で何もの小学生のお子さんに試作品や完成品のモニターお
願いしました
このランドセルを使った子がグラスに現れた時の驚き
こんなに軽いラーとせるがあるの
痛くないランプせるなんてあるの
こんなに荷物が入るの
今まで当たり前と思って使っていた
アド乱歩せるは当たり前じゃなかったのん
わくわくが止まらないんです
今まで自分が使っていたものに知らなかった選択肢があって
ものをもっと自由に選べるということに気が付いた時
それはお子さんのその後の j 性にも大きなポイントになるはずです
子どもたちが信じ込んで我慢している当たり前は当たり前じゃないこと
ものはもっと自由に選べるということをして固定関連を解放して軽やかに生き生きと
投稿してほしいとそう願っていました
でも実際スタートしてみると大きな壁は
子どもたちの当たり前の壁ではなく
大人のみんなと同じがいいという壁が私たちの前にお子さんにたどり着く前に
おおきくおおきく立ちふさがりました
みんなと違うものがいい
と言いたいわけでは決してありません
従来のランドセルがおかしいと言いたいわけでもないです
ただ
その選び方でいいですかということ
自分が使うものを選ぶ一番重要なポイントが
みんなと同じか違うか
ではない
そのことに気がついて欲しいんです
お子さんももちろん大人もです
例えば
子供が
これだけの水を運ばなくてはいけないとなったら
どうするのがいいのか
冷静に考えて
いくつもの選択肢を見せてあげたいと思いませんか
今日はたまたまランドセルの話をしましたが
実際似たような事例は身の回りにたくさんあるんだと思います
ちょっと見方を変えてみませんか
なんで当たり前って思っちゃってたんだろうねってよく言われるです
選択肢が広がるのってすっごくワクワクしますよね
そのワクワクで
子どもたちの未来が変わることを信じています
まだ自分で選択肢を見つけ出すことができない子どもたちに
広がる自由で大きな未来に
必要な一歩は周りの音だからの一歩です
まずはあなたの周りからここ浜松から
子どもたちの風景を変えてみませんか
物事がより良い方向に変わっていくことは
思っているより簡単であって欲しいと願っています
[拍手]